now I think I'm live I see the green
dots the green square that was weird
maybe something was wrong with you with
the connection or something I'm back for
another quick stream I leech s in the
st. Louis Chess Club YouTube suit or not
the YouTube studio just so the chess to
do this will probably be on YouTube at
some point I'm gonna play one rapid game
in the weekly rapid arena
is to get some Chesson before before
more chests darts for the day and I'm
playing Patrick H who plays an orangutan
also known as a Polish uh which is not
considered the best opening in chess
because of this line actually a your
Bishop take before a knight f6 black
just accelerates developments a three
let's play Bishop a5
and I know it's weird to may betray the
center pond for a winged pawn but it's
justified in the sense that black it's
just almost completing development
before white can uh can develop anything
I can play knight c6 here
what else to play this guy seems
somewhat prepared play rook e8 with
tempo like play d5
defy looks enticing
because I want to open the center before
a white can castle lady five
and okay finally I have the chat open
hello Pedro Ascencio thanks for being
the first commenter
this is probably gonna be like a 15 or
20 minute stream I don't have too much
time today because we have we have a
run-through to get through and then
we're doing commentary in in like an
hour hour and 45 minutes is starting so
it's probably the only game of the day
but I might be able to squeeze in one
more game after this we'll see Knight c3
so I want to kick the bishop but the
problem is if rookie a PI should take
out sex Queens I got six I lose a d5
pawn I might have to play a move like c6
here
which looks reasonable
oh he could still take on that six and
take on d5
interesting
I could take on c3 Bishop takes c3
Bishop takes c3 and then maybe something
like 94
we really want to give up the bishop
pair like that but let's do it
point 94
and I just want to take on c3 next he
moves the bishop again
I mean he's not developing anything else
looking to try and get some D for break
at some points it might be difficult
though I might have to develop first
looking at movies like rookie Yates
Bishop f5 maybe some eventual c5 in d4
he plays Rick b1
makes me want to play positionally like
if I just take the bishop on c3 I take
the pawn and c4
I'll have slightly better pawn structure
I don't know if I want to play like that
I could also take on c3 and then play
Queen f6 but then he has Queen d4
what to do
when h4 is a candidate move probably
runs into g3
also the idea of like taking on
c3 and then Bishop f5 and sacking the
b-pawn
or developments
I'm going to do it without too much
calculation
it might be a bad decision
but bad decisions lead to better stories
so can't complain with this hello to you
savage hello to muy knucks
hello gone man I'm doing well I'm very
busy this week thanks for the follow
Austin tired
reshape tax okay so he takes on b7 I'm
down upon but he's not developed
apart from the rook d7 some moves that
come to mind or Bishop b4
still Queen f6 ideas
see six but that seems kind of slow
looking at Queen f6 Queen d4 and then
Queen a6
rook b3
do it
so I'm thinking when his Queen comes to
d4 then I'll get some later tempo with
knight c6
it's all about keeping the initiative
and just not giving my time to develop
and these types of situations are
calming and opening but they're they're
tricky because if you give Y time to
consolidate then what will just be up
upon ya thanks for the comment skull
tide I am I'm dressed up because I'm
doing commentary later in the studio he
takes on c7 so now I'm down to pons but
I can just take on c3 and life is good
yeah and Queenie one check
expecting queen d1
and then I can take on a three
would take on a three there
you're probably pre-move queen take a
three but I won't do that because Queen
c1 is a illegal move for whites
okay take on a three now I'm threatening
this this fork on a five
but she misses
life is better now much better
you
so I'm not gonna continue playing this
tournament but if people have questions
or you want to play me you can send me a
challenge ponent offered me at draw
that's probably a mistake that was a
nice game though winning in 15 moves
for those of you who just joined I will
quickly show the game I feel like every
every player who takes opening seriously
should at least know how to play against
the Polish with this line 'if I've and
it should take me for being probably the
most recommended line at that black can
play as we saw in the game development
is sometimes more important than
material for a three Bishop a5 III
Castle C for white neglected to develop
any piece on the kingside the whole game
interrupts the queenside
but for me it was about opening up the
center Bishop takes c3 maybe
it was a somewhat controversial move but
I wasn't sure what else to do
there's so much pressure on g5 and I
don't want to take on c4 because then it
just helps them develop
I feel like I made the right decision
here
maybe I could play a move like 97 kinda
forgot about and then if he takes on
that six I just take back with my
Knights and then I get some temple in
the Bishop
yeah maybe 97 was stronger let's see
what stockfish says
in IBD seven by g4 I didn't even
consider that's interesting move though
ooh Knight g4 this would have been very
strong because when the bishop moves of
t4 completely miss sets
okay sock fish is good at chess
check to the king yeah I just started
I'm about to end it's gonna be a quick
stream I see a challenge from someone I
cannot play standard I just have a few
more minutes left I'm sure I'll be
around in the future to play longer
games but anyway just to wrap up this
game Bishop f5
activate the pieces and
this is a final moment where he should
probably play queen d4 I wasn't entirely
confident with what's happening in this
position after Queen a6 Brook to b3
I just assumed that there should be
something like maybe knight c6 is good
enough like knight c6 Queens eighty five
ninety seven I I keep hitting the Queen
and okay black is down to pawns but rook
t8 is coming and followed by some queen
a formative would be enough to who went
given the rook can't access this be one
square
okay Oh what else are you running to
show top games
I don't understand that question
Oh top games
hello to pass upon 99
I might have to go very soon I'm gonna
play messy Marvin in one quick game
yeah check to the king uh oh I already
said hello I think school tied if you
want to clarify your question play a
London always happy with the London
past pond 99 good to see you
you six play Knight c3
playing the Barry attack
and night b5 is a standard move here
I am disappointed when will use from you
properly next I'll stream
probably after this week is done for
those of you who don't know I'm doing
commentary at the st. Louis chess club
uh in in just over just over an hour and
a half I'll be live on the st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube channel with my good
friend and co commentator Catarina and M
Silva so you guys are free to watch that
if if you want to see more more of me
uh hello Karen Atlanta chess club bout
to Karen who I just saw over the weekend
I'm dressed up because I want to look
decent on camera 9 H 5 what is this move
let's keep my Bishop if he really wants
to win the bishop he could play h6 g5
but that's we can move to the Kings side
a weird position not entirely sure
what's going on here
but I do realize like both nights both
black nights are on the edge of the
board old saying goes at nights on the
rim or grin and those are that those
were the only develop pieces they see
three here defend
you might play ooh c41 so in the night I
have to play a four
I'm sure you will do great yeah today is
round 3 so we've already had one of two
two learning experiences it's the first
time that me and Katarina are doing
commentary like in the studio but
there's a lot to learn
we're overcoming our nerves and
hopefully it's instructive for the
viewers
might see seven as predicted I kind of
want to play b4 here
or maybe p3 it's like mmm
b3 is a plunger because we can see three
and I don't have too much times I think
when I play this move
strange but the idea is if he takes on
b5 twice I have b3 in the end and c4 is
attacked
is it dim and not grim dim and grim mean
the same thing right rim rim is sad him
is also kind of sad
you've enjoyed both round 1 and 2 well
thank you let me know if you have
feedback I'm sure there's things that we
can improve it's very difficult to like
to analyze positions and keep keep
talking while analyzing because
sometimes we both just want to sit and
think for a few minutes but we're trying
our best Bishop d7
don't want to play before let's play
before
they'll take on the c7 if he moves the
Queen
oh there's an interesting line if Queen
b6 I could take on c4 on take c4 Knight
takes e4 Queen d5 Knight e5
that just looks fun might be bad but it
looks fun
okay he's going for this line
which also looks relatively fun I have a
five here
but do I want to play that
oh this is prio so I probably should
move quickly
I probably should probably start to stop
looking at the chat - okay let's focus
uhh
the thing is attacked before doesn't
work I guess I have to take but then he
takes on c3 No
what am I doing here
oh no I take with check okay forgot that
was check like Queen d2 hasten kills 85
thanks for the bits hundred bits I'll
buy some
I'm caramel sauce and my coffee
I want to make Karen I'm not how do I
make Karen Ahmad and not flag ad friend
and no mod user okay now I have to play
quick moves I see an outpost square in
c5
oh he took my rook which I completely
forgot about it
as unfortunates
well at least he's thinking because the
position is slightly confusing and all I
need to do is move quickly enough I'm
down in the exchange
but okay I am I have some nice
compensation here my minor pieces are
happy his minor pieces sad pick on each
file
'if I've coming
he's gonna get for it oh no he's not cuz
he has Queen b5 check by G for pawn
storm
I still want to play 97 I need to put
the king on g2 first or I just I can
probably just flag him 96 was a terrible
move okay not the cleanest game
I usually reflexively say good game but
but that was interesting
unfortunate I don't have too much time
to analyze I don't think c5 should be
played so early cuz my p5 is usually
pretty annoying for black um hello to
nerve on Raymond thanks for joining
but unfortunately I do have to go is we
were doing like rehearsal before the
actual commentary starts so before I
leave it pause a tournament
let's see who's streaming
[Music]
Caleb's streaming
I just kind of want a stream or a de
uh somebody on Ripley hello - Bruna rola
I do have to go I know my up time was
not impressive today we're gonna raid
this guy and then I will I will be back
in the future have a good day everyone
any catchphrases I'm working on not at
the current moment
I guess I'll be back in the future is
one of my catchphrases so let me type in
raid
great Tom Ripley and goodbye everyone